[Applause]
I don't know about her I'm just she's
out of she don't know if she's in this
world or
not
W who El was in the
caries okay the baby that's in the back
lifeless
okay get out of my car who is that
that's Myck my connect in there where's
my other one he's in the ambulance
my
hand you don't even know where your kids
are you're going to jail going to
jail know you're in
this come here come on baby you leave oh
my
go let's take a seat she
bre no baby let me come you my baby let
go take a seat okay please let me come
you with my baby
the matter right now is the babies
please why would you let me do talk to
my baby do you have any weapons on you
no I got nothing put this down okay no
have anything do you have any needles on
you
no all right take a seat right here for
now please please
where I need a be can I go see here can
we go
baby let me have that here not right
now school bus going to have to turn
around worked I just did a so where were
you coming from today then right now
before the crash what do you mean where
you come from when you were driving on
the road where did you leave from the
house you left your house where were you
going the Christies and from the store
Christies and then the store yeah okay
okay um
what happened with the crash do you
remember it at all I turned my head look
the girls to talk to him they're
fighting I just turned my head
okay all right so you haven't used meth
since yesterday then right right I took
my sleeping pill last night you took
your sleeping pill last night yes I did
it every night I everybody all right
well I'm going to run you through a few
field ofri test here okay um I'm going
to check your eyes first do the uh
horizontal gaze test here okay all right
on this test what you're going to do is
you're just going to follow this pin
with your eyeballs only as it goes from
side to side you're going to keep your
head dead straight okay so the only
thing moving here is your eyes and
you're going to track this pin all right
you have any questions about any of that
can you see the pin just fine
okay Al so you can can blink if you need
to during this test you don't have to
keep your eyes open
okay
all PR thing about my oldest daughter
your
oldest focus on this for a second this
one's going to go all the way
out
wait place for yeah after a little
little
bit we're going to do that one again cuz
you kept looking everywhere else all
right just going to stay out here to
your right or to your
left
okay all
right I'm do the modified rberg test on
this next one here okay I'm going to
explain it all to you and I'm going to
ask you to take it from there all right
it's pretty simple test what you're
going to do here is you're going to have
your feet side by side like you already
have them you're going to have your hand
straight down to your side
okay from there you're going to look up
at the sky with your eyes closed no I'm
going to fall over than that okay I'm CL
well I'll catch you if you fall
over like I said with your head back I'm
going you don't have to do it yet I'm
going to explain everything to you then
then I want you to do it all right so
put your hands down to your side you
want to maintain that straight stance
there you're going to lift your head up
till you're looking at the clouds you're
going to close your eyes all right if
your head back and your eyes closed
you're going to quietly to yourself
estimate the passage of 30 seconds okay
when you think 30 seconds is passed
you're going to drop your head into tell
me to stop timing you okay do you have
any questions about any of that all
right like I said just like this hands
straight down to your side head up eyes
closed when I tell you to start that's
when you're going to estimate the
passage in 30 seconds okay go ahead and
get in the position I'll tell you to
start in just a
second got to have your eyes
closed start
now
okay are you done yeah how long was that
I think it was 30 but that kept getting
on my elbow so how did you get to 30
count one two three one two three okay
then I stopped for a second when I said
calling on me okay so you had a little
pause there in the middle and you just
kept on going you just count to 30 then
mhm okay all right um how do how do you
ingest your pills and your meth when you
take them do you sort them yeah okay how
do you how do you explain having zero
nasal hair in your nose idea that was
from a years ago probably years ago yeah
you to sort Xanax or something yeah
Xanax okay how long ago has it been
since you done that about five days when
they did that last days did last all
right because I pass away okay have you
smoked any marijuana or anything like
that today I don't smoke marijuana okay
all right all right let's step over here
into the middle so I don't so you don't
fall off the road here
out all right this next test is going to
be the walk and turn test all right I'm
going to explain everything to you and
I'm going to show you what it should
look like then I'm going to ask you to
do it all
right for this test you need to start
out with your uh right foot in front of
your left so let us touch and Heel To
Toe just like mine is right here go
ahead and do that now I can't even do
that all right and your hands your hands
straight down to your side all right do
it stay like that till I finish
explaining this to you from there you're
going to take nine Heel To Toe steps
right down this straight line here okay
I got to melt a rod all way from the top
of this leg to the bottom okay see the
scoring from the pins and everything in
it does that hurt you right now yeah
hurts me especially the weather okay uh
but I I said from there you're going to
take nine Heel To Toe steps right down
this line all right while you're taking
them nine Heel To Toe steps you're going
to look down at your feet you're going
to count out every step out loud so that
I can hear you okay you're going to keep
your hands down to your side the entire
time you're taking this test all right
when you get to that ninth Heel To Toe
step you're going to leave your front
foot on the line you're going to Pivot
around your front foot with a series of
small steps to change direction okay and
then you're going to return right back
down the same line taking nine more Heel
To Toe steps looking down at your feet
counting every step out loud with your
hands down to side all right I'm going
to show you what this is going to look
like so one 2 3 all the way out to nine
when you get to that ninth step you're
going to leave that front foot on the
line like mine is here you're going to
Pivot around it with a series of small
steps like I'm doing right now then
you're going to return right back down
the same line nine more Heel To Toe
steps looking down at your feet counting
every step out loud one two three all
the way out to nine do you have any
questions about any of
that
I don't
know they might have had another
call look up or look down look can every
step out loud like I told
you even do
it it's horrible I can't do this thing
so I can't do it sorry I mean l this
over and I'm freezing
now
[Music]
6 7 8 9
10 okay all right I got one more test
here for you all right I'm going to
explain this one to you as well this
test is going to be
your feet together just like they were
for the first test we did your hands
straight down to your side okay from
there it's whatever foots most
comfortable for you you're going to
raise one foot off the ground about 6 in
all right you're going to keep a
straight leg when you raise that foot
that foot that's off the ground is going
to be parallel to the ground as if
you're pointing your toes like I'm doing
here all right so with your hand
straight down to your side and that foot
6 in off the ground and parallel to the
ground you're going to look at those
toes you have raised and you're just
going to count 1,1 1,2 13 1004 out loud
until I tell you to stop counting okay
do you have any question questions about
any of that can my sweatshir I'm not
shaking
so is it in the back stay right there
for a
second
my
put that
on my
now oh my
God boxing too just I'm going to explain
this to you one more time here okay feet
together hands down to your side with
the straight leg leg you're going to
raise one foot off the ground about 6 in
you're going to keep that foot parallel
ground all right while you're you're
going to maintain that position you're
going to look at your toes you have off
the ground you're going to count 1,1
1002 1003 till I tell you to stop
counting okay do you have any questions
about
that all right start that one want to be
best it's whatever foot you want start
it whenever you're
ready
3 2004 2005
20067 2008
20090 11 12 13
hard my balance is not
great okay you can relax I'm up on top
of
it my care about is all right is there
any chance you're pregnant right now no
not pregnant at all okay actually that
time right now mon okay like down turn
around for
me do you have any shoulder
injuries not that you know
well window
myid
hurt
actually face me this
way damn it's
cold
listen right now you're under arrest for
OVI okay okay I'm going to read you your
rights before we go any further you have
the right to remain silent anything you
say can will be used against you in
court you have the right to talk to a
lawyer for advice before we ask you any
questions have a lawyer present with you
during questioning if you're un aable to
pay a lawyer one will be appointed for
your priority in questioning if you so
desire if you wish to answer questions
now without a lawyer present you have
the right to stop answering questions at
any time uh you have the right to stop
answering
questions anytime until you talk to your
lawyer all right do you understand your
Miranda right yeah
right